Welcome to Pod two fifty six, number one twenty five, 09/21/2026.
Yo. Yo. Let's dive right into it. It's been an exciting couple of weeks, so let's start with some network stats. Hash rate, currently floating around 936
x a hash, nine sixty on the three day moving average, nine thirty one on the seven day. Difficulty,
currently one thirty two point seven six trillion with the last retarget going up 4.16%.
I believe that was at block height 967,680
on September 19, so just a couple days ago.
Next retarget,
I mean, probably not even worth mentioning at this point because it's so variable at the beginning of the difficulty epoch.
Average reward 3.146
bitcoin
and
seven day
average
for who's dominating the network. Foundry
is leading at 23.7%
followed by amp pool at 20.3%
with f two pool in third place at 16%.
Sorry about the background noise. My dog is drinking water and my three d printer is just buzzing along over there.
Full operation going. We're multitasking here. Yeah. Yeah. We're doing all sorts of fun stuff. Those are some interesting stats on the
seven day
average of who's hit the most blocks. Ocean down
quite a bit. Yeah, down to 1.8%.
That sucks.
What happened there? What could they have possibly done wrong? They bounced back after the BIP 1.10
thing. They bounced back to,
I don't know, over 3%,
it sounds like.
Yeah,
looks
like they're up at 3.3%,
now they're back down to 1.8. Interesting. Mean, look, it's probably best for Ocean that they cut mechanic loose
and Luke is on like perma sabbatical.
I don't honestly, I don't think he'll that's just what they tell you, but I don't think he'll ever come back from that. Right? I don't know. Scott's running the numbers on it. I'm running the numbers. He's fact checking everything. He doesn't trust the agent.
Good job. Well, I was just looking at the hash rate reported on Ocean's website, which they say is 21.63x
a hash, which looks like it's about 2.3%.
I don't know. The plot thickens. Well, that stat 1.8 is of the past ten sixteen blocks.
That's a good point. There we go. Now we're So there's obviously some luck involved in all this.
That would be an interesting metric to include if we repeat these updates as like who had the most luck
proportion with our hash rate. Yeah. We had a fun time on our two fifty six chat
talking about different things we could add to the dashboard,
which I think luck would be a cool one, like individual miner luck. We could see like
have a
leaderboard for the luckiest miner. I like that. Yeah. So on -.256f.org
which is our hosted instance of HydraPool,
the open source mining pool project that Zhongli is the lead architect of. There's been some recent updates by D plus plus friend of the show, amazing supporter,
lovely gal, to make it more gamified.
And really the update
is to show the
second second place place is is the the first loser. So we're looking at the top 20 losers now because it now shows the top 20 or so results on the difficulty and loyalty leaderboard. You have a higher chance of getting on there now, you know? If you're not first, you're last. That's right. So there's a number of ways to measure first, right? So we can see, you know, who's got the most hash rate pointed
and in that category,
Zarka is leading the
group here at 15.4
terahash,
so it doesn't take a whole lot to be first.
No. I'm in fourth place myself with 7.8
terahash.
Tyler,
you're down there in like what, sixth or seventh? Yeah. 4.6,
and Scott's on here.
I don't know, maybe, I didn't Oh man. Just under a terahash with the Park Austin hydro axe. Anyways, yeah, we can measure by hash rate, which is cool. Pretty straightforward.
We can measure by who submitted the most hashes to the pool,
which is the loyalty leaderboard,
right?
Yep, and it gets reset if you have a seven day window where you submit zero hashes. Right, okay. That's why I got, okay, was looking at the wrong one. Yeah, on the loyalty leader board, Schnitzel,
for example, had rented
over an Exahash for a period of time during our last
telehash fundraiser.
So he submitted a total of like 3.08
zeta hashes to HydroPool,
and he's maintained that position even though he only submitted that exahash for like thirty minutes or an hour, but he hasn't stopped hashing completely
with at least one miner. So even if he's just got one bid axe pointed at the pool, he his
his leadership
position there stays at the top. He's got his four twenty two Giga Hash fish tank axe still going strong.
That keeps Holding it up.
That keeps him afloat there, right? And then we have difficulty, right, Eco? Another metric. Yeah. And then that's the one I skipped. So yeah, difficulty is
who's
gotten the closest to hitting that golden nonce.
Electron has held that first place position
since,
was it May?
Mhmm. Yeah, think that was in May, yeah during the telehash. So they got a 5,640,000,000,000
difficulty
and that's kept them in first place ever since.
I like that it puts the worker name. You can see the electron worker name is just an IP address of that machine. Yeah. Yeah. Maybe dates would be good. Is that what you're saying, Scott? Yeah. Because I saw that
megawatt was always quite lucky is in third place. I was curious when that happened. Was that during the telehash? I think that was telehash four, yeah,
back in May of this year. Okay. This another reason why luck would be cool to have, right? You could see, you know, like, of course, electron got it because they were pointing like six
exahash,
but it'd be cool to see who is just ridiculously lucky and got a high difficulty with minimal hash or minimal time. Yep. I think that would be a good metric to have. And then in our chat, we were debating how to notate
the values for the loyalty leaderboard,
which was an interesting conversation. I've got a new proposal. All right. So
I was originally proposing we use scientific notation for the number of hashes, which maybe is both hard to understand and a mouthful to read live on the on the pod. But what if we instead of saying units like Zeta
and Exa that no one really knows, what if we did instead of 3.08
Zeta hash, we did 3,080,000?
And just talk about everything in terahashes? Yeah. We just do million trillion. Keep it below
just keep stacking on,
what are they called, decades
that are
trillions,
billions and millions. Yeah, because what occurred to me when we were having this conversation, there was,
I think, three different ideas for how to present that number.
And it occurred to me that all three of them really do become quite abstract
the larger these numbers get. I was like, you know, my main complaint with the scientific notation was like, well, you know, I flunked out of math and don't know what, you know, 10 to the power of 22 means. So that isn't it doesn't really tell me anything. But at the same time, if it had just said quintillion,
I wouldn't I don't necessarily
know what that means either.
Right. Quincyan,
quadrillion, which one's more? Yeah. But scientific notation is easy. It's like if it's 10 to the 21, there's 21 zeros added to the end of the number. Yeah, but I don't know what
what is that? I know that's a lot, but then I have, like anybody knows these numbers that large. Yeah. That's that's a good point. Right? So you only if you're looking at this, kinda have that rule of thumb that, like, million is six and billion is nine and trillion is 12, but that's yeah, it starts to break down pretty quickly when you get past that. Yeah, past a trillion, I'm just like, if it's a number larger than The US national deficit,
I'm just kind of at a loss. It makes me think when
Bitcoin miners talk to you about their price of electricity in dollars per megawatt hour or Yeah. It's a weird Or they put hash price in petahash. I'm like, dude, that's how I know you're not a home miner.
That's true. We need price per terahash and cost per kilowatt hour for it to be relatable. Although I imagine we'll eventually measure home miners and cost per petahash. And megawatts.
That'd be awesome. Use megawatts at the home? Oh yeah. Megawatts at the home is
that's a lot. That's the goal. That's the dream. Get those little like micro reactors at home and be like, Oh yeah.
Yeah. So check out the dash.256f.org
and we'll probably continue to make updates to it. There were a lot of good ideas in the group chat this past week about gamifying it further. I'd like to see what the chances are
of hitting a block in a day given the current hash rate at
any given time on the dashboard. It's always a little disappointing.
Maybe
a year? Never show me the odds? Never show me the odds.
Yeah. I
think Public Pool has that though. Yeah. We could stretch it out to like, the odds look really good at 60,
which is about what we have right now, 70 terahash,
at hitting a block between now and the year 2140
when the last subsidy coin is paid out.
I think we have a one in two chance at hitting a block by then. That'd be a fun metric. Chances of getting a Coinbase payout while there's still a thing. Yeah. While there's still the last coins? The last subsidy is gonna be in sats, but how many sats is it? This is a fun, tricky question, which I don't know the answer to. I know this answer can be derived, but I don't have it off the top of my head. I'm gonna guess 21 sats. Oh, that would be amazing. I don't think the math works out quite that well, but let's
I don't think the math works out cleanly at all. Like, it had to be It doesn't.
Hard coded, right? I think so. I'm gonna ask Chad GPT because
that's just how we answer questions now. That's right. Yeah. 60
terahash, 73 terahash right now on the Hashdash, but we had a peak of four thirty terahash over the past week. Thanks to our friends at Riot over in Switzerland with their solar miner that is implementing Mugena.
They've been pointing their development
systems as they build out this product to the Hashdash, which is cool. We can Very log kind, very generous of them to do that. Thank you. We appreciate all the support. Oh, it's one stat. All right, there we go. That does it. One stat? No way. Yeah. So is there gonna be a epoch
prior to that that's paying out two sats per block?
Yeah,
I think so. Let's see. And then an
epoch that's paying out four sats, eight sats, $16.32,
and there must be. Yeah, it's two. I think it's just bit shifting.
For four years, people are gonna be getting two sats per block that they mine? Yeah. That's wild. They could be very valuable. Or I guess the correct way to put that is for, what is it, 210,000
blocks, people are gonna be getting four sats per block and then two sats per block and then one sat per block and then no more Coinbase or no more subsidy
included in the Coinbase. Dang. Hope there's a lot of transaction fees. Right. Yeah. I hope people actually use Bitcoin on chain. That's a problem for tomorrow.
Yeah. That is funny. I mean, yeah, if the Bitcoin price goes up enough to make that worthwhile, then I guess fees would also
well, fees would have to be less than a sat. I mean yeah. And people are already doing, like, sub one sat fees on their transactions,
so I think that'll continue.
But according to mempool.space
right now, less
than 85,000
transactions
waiting to be confirmed,
so for a global monetary system, I don't think that's
a whole lot of usage. Very underutilized
network here in my opinion. The average
reward
is
2,100,000
sats over the last 144
blocks in fees. Yeah above the block subsidy. Pretty thin margins for minors if you think about it. Not a lot of meat on that bone right now. No. Yeah did you see Safedine's
article about how he has a hypothesis that we've seen the peak total
power or energy consumption of the Bitcoin mining network as a whole. Really? No, didn't see that. He thinks
that
energy consumption to run Bitcoin mining will go down from here? Or perhaps plateau,
but yes, more or less that was the thesis of the article was that now that the large on grid miners are shifting to AI
and as it trickles into smaller,
more off grid energy sources that we might not see another, a new peak, a new all time high in total energy consumption used for mining. I don't necessarily agree just because I think we've all seen all the innovative ways you can integrate miners into different systems. But it's an I interesting
haven't read the article, but I guess another factor to that would be the chip efficiency continues to
get better. So less energy per terahash produced, right?
Yeah, think the network hash rate, I don't think he was arguing that would stop increasing.
I think there's that Cambridge
Analytics dashboard,
excuse me, that tracks,
that estimates,
like what percentage of global energy consumption is spent on Bitcoin that used to be a big FUD metric. Right. Yeah. Yeah, no, I'm not saying that
I wasn't bringing that up to point out the hash rate. It was that
to maintain current hash rate levels, if efficiency keeps getting better would require less energy. That's true, yeah.
The Bitcoin price
the
block subsidy reward, right, those also play into it.
Well, and then, you know, everyone's going to be using Ripple,
so like why
even bother with Bitcoin?
I can't even keep a straight face. When I read that article from SAFE, I
immediately thought, man, I think a lot of people's perception
about what mining is and what mining isn't is purely based off what Bitmain tells you a miner is. And we talked about this at the event we were at together a couple weeks back now in San Francisco where people have in their head that a miner is this shoebox. Right? And it's like if someone said, Hey, computers will never fit in your hand. They'll never fit in a laptop. They're just always going to be room sized things and there's only so many rooms on earth that can fit a computer this big. It's like, Well, at the end of the day, a miner needs to do what? Just like issue new coins, settle transactions and secure the blockchain from double spend attacks. So I think that could come in various shapes and sizes. Can you guys still hear me?
Yeah. Yeah. Oh, I got a weird notice on my screen. Sorry.
But yeah, don't assume my fucking gender.
No, I'm joking, but like, yeah, why do they get to define what a miner is? Like, we can do that too. And I think we are doing that at the two fifty six Foundation.
We're changing what that definition is. I mean, like, at a certain level, a miner mines Bitcoin. Like, that's what we're talking about here, right? But beyond that, why does it have to be this fucking shoebox
that Bitmain produces or that What's Miner produces? Like, it doesn't have to be that.
And it doesn't have to be purpose built for
a warehouse setting.
It can take many different forms, and we're figuring out that it requires an open source
foundation of solutions
to make that sort of technological
development happen. Yeah. It's just taking the current status quo and extrapolating it forward into the future,
Not taking into account new developments
and new use cases and things which, I guess, we're well aware
are If
you talk to people in the oil field who are capturing flared gas to mine Bitcoin and ask them, like, what is your ideal
Bitcoin miner? They're probably gonna have a much different answer
than
someone who has a solar panel on the roof of their home that's trying to capture excess energy and monetize it into SATs.
And
a Bitcoin miner can be both of those answers,
but we need to know
what those look like and make it happen and develop it. I think that development only happens when
the whole stack is broken open into these open source solutions that we're building. So this is kind of like a shameless plug for the two fifty six Foundation and you can donate at 256foundation.org
but
yeah, I think that's where this is going. A 100% and that's how, if you're a new listener,
that is how Eco and Rod when founding this organization identified the core
pillar projects of our foundation, the hash board reference design, control board reference design, open source firmware and open source mining pool instance because those are, as I framed them,
I put an article out on our website and a video I recorded following a fundraiser we did last week or two weeks back, where these are the domain specific building blocks that make up a Bitcoin miner. You need those things to mine Bitcoin. They can come in different shapes and sizes, right? But you need those things to mine Bitcoin to run that part of the protocol.
And who knows what that's going to look like? That's why we need to just put the open source building blocks out there and say, Okay, go do, like go build your thing and see what works and see what doesn't work. Then who knows ten, twenty years from now what the status quo of a Bitcoin miner will be. When you say computer nowadays, people probably think laptop. Don't think giant room
sized
vacuum tube machine. Well, and to give credit where credit is due, Scott was
instrumental
in helping define
what those four areas were going to be for the foundation. You know, Rod and I had identified that like, we want to build a business in Bitcoin mining.
Doing it with closed source
shoebox miners really sucks and is not tenable. If it were open source technology, we could modify these things to fit our unique business model and really get some juice out of it. So we knew that much,
but what that really meant and really defining what we're going to do about it, that came over a number of months when Rod and I had started the foundation and got a little bit of help from our friends at Foundry
and HeatBit
and HRF.
We had started the Ember One project and I knew
that we wanted to work with Scott on
We knew,
all right, we need to have an open source hash board, so let's start there.
Scott was the first guy that we approached,
and then over the next several months, Scott and I were meeting every week developing the Ember one, and in our discussions,
that's really where these other areas where things became much more clear. And it was like, well, if we're doing this hash board, we're really going to need a control board to talk to it. We're really going to need a firmware
to
interface with everything.
I was like, yeah, and we should have a mining pool.
And I also had this idea for a dashboard
thing, but
we ended up letting go of that one. But that's really where those four ideas came from.
And if it weren't for Scott, I'm not sure I would've had that clarity. It's so fun to dig into this stuff and be like, oh my gosh. Like, this is how it comes together. And these are the pieces. And, like, it's hard, but it's not that hard. We can make these things. And then, of course, we were lucky enough to solve the block at the first telehash, and I was like, all right, let's fucking go. Yeah, it's an amazing story. It's even more amazing to think that
one of the core functions of the Bitcoin protocol is reliant entirely on a permissioned technology stack. Yeah, it's bullshit.
I don't think people really realize that. No. I don't think they do. And I've been thinking more about it too because Scott, you had this idea. You brought up a really good point when we were prepping for the fundraiser was, you know, it's not really in a company's best interest all the time to just give away all of their IP and innovation and release the source to everything, or at least this is how they think in some ways. They want to keep it to themselves, It's their competitive edge. It's their special sauce. But the interesting thing about Bitcoin mining is that it started open source. There were commoditized building blocks for computers. Open source
operating systems exist like Linux, right? There are various vendors and suppliers. It's a natural
healthy ecosystem that went through its own quirks
as personal computing manifested.
But it's just funny that when Bitcoin was released,
the permissioned nature of the tools you needed for mining was not the case.
And then it evolved into
ASICs,
which then a few companies seized
the competitive edge on and then closed it. And I don't know of another instance where that's happened,
where a project kind of started open, then its natural evolution
from an efficiency standpoint, a technology standpoint, a performance standpoint led to it kind of getting the door closed on it. My dad always tells me this story. I guess the guy that invented the sewing machine
was
very
well, he did he did very well for himself because he didn't patent the sewing machine. He patented the needle,
which is the, like, critical part to making a sewing machine work because they have to, like, use two different, like, spools of thread from the top and the bobbin on the bottom and, like, hook it together with the needle. And that was the key part. Right? And so patenting that made it so that no one else could make a sewing machine. But, you know, patents run out. People people move on. And so now anyone can make a sewing machine. Right? It seems like early on in these technologies, you have people who are investing a lot of time and money,
you know,
basically by their lonesome to to develop these things. And so they keep it private so their competitors don't get the edge. But then, you know, it it's a fantastic invention,
and lots of other people, it changes the world and lots of other people want to work on this. And so then these things tend to open up. I mean, think also personal computers,
when they first started, when it kind of got out of the mainframe
in universities
and businesses then personal computers started. It was also very proprietary,
and every different company made their own OS.
And then it kind of coalesced into a couple proprietary
OSs.
And then now we're seeing, you know, it's obviously essential to human progress,
and,
you know, it's it's it's wide open for the better.
I think it kinda speaks to Bitcoin mining just being early. But things technology moves very fast now. Like, it increases at an exponential rate here. So I think the rate in which we'll see these things get developed,
proprietary, and then open up, that, like, whole, like, timeline is is just dramatically shortened. Yeah. It's I had an interesting conversation with Schnitzel this morning about the Libra board,
which we've
started actively working on again.
And one of the things he was saying is that a few months ago when we were doing Revision three earlier in the year,
we were using AI to help us do that. And one of the things the AI told us to change in the way the USB was configured
seemed totally fine at the time.
But then we found out there was some kind of problem. There was something going on, and we were trying to identify it. So now that we're actively working on it again, and it's been a few months, he pointed AI at the same problem again, and AI had identified
that there was a issue in that USB
configuration
that AI wasn't able to identify, that AI,
in fact, incorrectly instructed us to do
just a few months ago. So just in a few months, AI went from telling
us
incorrectly how to put this USB
controller on there to now telling us, identifying that that is incorrect and telling us how to do it a different way now.
So cool. It's just the development is just breakneck speed with this stuff. Well, what's also interesting there is AI feeds off data
and
relatively Bitcoin mining compared to everything else that AI is trained on. There's not that much information out there. Our foundation,
the people in OSMU and heat punks, home tinkerers,
people hacking miners are
putting that data out there in real time. Right? And so in just a few short months, like there might be way more available for an AI to scrounge from the internet and learn about how Bitcoin mining works. So I'm sure you'd see some rapid changes in what what's going on too, which is fun. Yeah, definitely. Yeah. That's that's huge. Right? I mean, before,
I mean, in the before times before AI was really useful, right? You could Google something like how does the BM thirteen sixty six mining ASIC work, and there was just nothing. Right?
Absolutely nothing. And now you'll get a ton of results as how to do it. And even better is the AI is aware of those results,
and you can actually just it it blows my mind to just have, like, a cohesive
conversation with an AI chatbot where it knows the intricate details of how these mining ASICs work. Right? And it it got that because of what this community made. Right? Like, AI is not going to hook up a logic analyzer to the ASIC and figure out how it works. Right? Mhmm. It got that because someone did it and posted it.
So,
yeah, it's This is exponential progress. The
very basic principle in computing that the computer only knows what the user is inputting into it. Like, that principle is still true today, like even with AI. Like yes,
AI can like
deduce,
you know, use reason and like draw conclusions
and infer things from the information that it's given, But like that
information has to be provided to it in the first place. It doesn't have
the basic human experiences that we all have.
Yeah, I mean, that's that is a really good argument for the necessity of something like two fifty six Foundation
to be out there and to be supported and long lasting is to keep, you know, sort of doing that original research and publishing it and connecting the dots, putting everything out there so that then people can take, you know, their engineering staff armed with their AI tools and just start
working forward instead of reverse engineering and start making those connections and getting done what they want to do in Bitcoin mining. And it further
reinforces
using community tools as well. If you solve something, you know, write a blog post on the two fifty six Foundation forum because some AI is gonna find that, scrape it, learn from it and save someone else a lot of time. So just having the community infrastructure is also helpful. Indeed, yeah. Because a lot of times these, you know, these chats,
signal chats you might have with your homies while you're working on this stuff, like that's not, you know, getting part of the the public record. So, you know, posting this stuff out there is is really helpful for builders. I found this AI tool that just scrapes old Nissan and Toyota forums and Nice.
And
reads old service manuals from the dealers. And it's just got an API endpoint, and it knows absolutely everything about my truck. And it's amazing torque specs. I'll be like, what's the torque spec of this random nut?
And it's like, here you go. Take a picture, you're like, what's this? Yeah. How tight does that need to be? Yeah. Oh man. But they had extensive documentation and they had the community sources for decades where people added their own information, their own hacks, tricks, whatever it may be
and it's absolutely
accelerated the way these tools are available to help people in niche, in otherwise what would be niche things, 30 year old Nissan trucks.
Yeah. It exists. Such a good idea too because there's always been repair guides for for vehicles. Right? But if you've ever tried to, like, do anything based on one of those alone, it's always they just skip steps,
and they're like, oh, yeah. Putting it back together, just do everything in reverse. And it's just it's so easy to get lost. And so hence, these forums come up where people are, like, actually dealing with the real issues. Yeah. Well, and and a lot of those
there's just a lot of, like,
you know, mechanics specifically. Like, that's been my wheelhouse for my whole adult life. And it's there's just a lot of, like,
knowledge, like foundational mechanical
knowledge
that
one would possess when they're, like, reading those manuals. So it's it's kind of similar to, like,
GitHub repositories.
When you look at a GitHub repository for a project,
the developer
has written the software and the readme page has some real basic instructions on how to get it working. But unless
you are experienced
doing development and
pulling in repositories
and
entering stuff in command line, there's so much detail that's kind of lost in translation there. But if you're just a complete novice and you've never used command line and you just follow the instructions in the readme file step by step, it's like you just,
you can't
do it because there's just certain steps that it's like you would only know if you've done it before. The field knowledge, yeah. Yeah, so like for example, if the command says
enter this prompt and then it's got the brackets and it says your IP address.
Someone who's
never done this before is literally gonna copy that text string and put it in the command line and be like, why am I getting this fucking error? I'm doing what it says to do. They
just don't know any better. So it's the same thing with mechanical stuff. It's like there's just some really basic knowledge that one would need to possess to be able to use that manual
to
make a repair.
And there's, like, a lot of that stuff just isn't really spelled out in the step by step guide. Like like when you like, it never tells you, like, make sure you buy a second 10 millimeter socket because you're going to lose your 10 millimeter socket.
Like,
you know, shit like that. So
sorry for the background noise.
I'm gonna make my dog shut up. Yeah. It's called charm.
Chatwithcharm.com.
Verified OEM automotive data, 1982 to 2013.
Amazing. Amazing. I wanna do that. I wanna do that. It's always so frustrating working on old cars not being like a seasoned mechanic.
It's just like, oh, yeah. Like, you know, to change your remove your transmission, it's just these like four easy steps. Well, and stuff changes, right? Like
the
manufacturer
recommended
transmission fluid
from 1995 is not the same anymore. And if you get the wrong one, it might eat away and disintegrate the synchros in your gearbox, right?
And thank God someone
wrote a forum post about how it nuked their transmission when they poured the wrong transmission fluid in
And so that's value
of these types of platforms for community knowledge, field knowledge to be shared. So if you are new to 256 or a veteran tinkering like I'm thinking of iX Tech for example, he's doing some cool stuff with Magina.
Contributing PRs and issues on the code base is great, but then if you've got some field knowledge, that's another thing that would be excellent to put on the forum. On that point, did you know the
brake fluid specifications
are all backwards compatible but not forward compatible?
No. So for example, if your vehicle calls for DOT three specific brake fluid,
you can use DOT five specific brake fluid in your vehicle. However, if your vehicle calls for DOT five brake fluid and you use DOT three rated brake fluid, you may have problems because of that. Good to know. There you go. Thanks for tuning in, folks. Especially when you roll into the store and they don't have DOT three because it's like some esoteric one that you know, it's just not available.
Right? Right. It's
pro tips. I just realized I wasn't supposed to be putting ethanol gas in my truck for the past 10,000 miles. I fucking hate ethanol, dude. I go to a non ethanol gas station now, is super expensive, but,
yeah, it erodes ethanol erodes old rubber compounds, it will just destroy your fuel lines.
My conspiracy is they're trying to get old cars that they can't track off the road. You know what's fucked up is the
Dodge Ram
2,500
for a number of years has been using a
soy
based
product in their fuel lines that
squirrels can detect and they will go and like chew on these fuel, they'll go crawl into the parked vehicle and chew up these fuel lines because they're attracted to the soy product. It's genius. We're going to use fuel to grow corn to then turn corn
back into fuel
for vehicles that need fuel. Makes I perfect
swear to God, the whole 10% ethanol thing was
SIOP from big corn agriculture.
And they were like, We need the government to mandate
that they're using this stuff so that there's always a need for our product. I mean, they've always been looking for uses for corn, right? That's how we got corn syrup and stuff. Right? Because they subsidize the hell out of corn in this country. And then they're like, ah, but it kinda sucks to just straight up give the farmers money. So, like, what can can we do anything with this corn? Totally. Just make things that are bad for cars, bad for humans. Yeah. It'll be great. Awful. But good for money printing. Good for money. What else is going on in Bitcoin mining? Let's see. Do we wanna talk about the fundraiser and what we did? Yeah. Yeah, we should. I alluded to it a couple times. We had the whole team together.
I posted a photo it's in that article right up on 256foundation.org
but we were all fortunate enough to get out to San Francisco two weekends ago now for a fundraiser
in person fundraiser we held for open source mining along with our friends at Localhost Research. Shout out to them, big supporters.
Huge shout to them. Huge shout them and huge shout out to the Presidio Bitcoin venue and team there,
Alex and Hayley at Spiral and those folks. We got to turn it into a multi pronged trip. We went a couple of days early so that we could attend the Open Source AI Summit, which was also fascinating and relevant
to what we're working on per Eco's little tangent there.
But yeah, the
structure of the event was awesome. We got to give an intro. Eco talked about kind of the pain points that he also mentioned on this pod of home mining and how that led to the foundation of an organization and bringing on the initial team and now what we're at with our projects and our vision for building these open source building blocks. Then I really like the workshops, so I'll hand it off there so Scott can talk about his, but we broke out into workshops with all of the project leads and kept people engaged instead of just scrolling on their phone in front of us talking for two hours. Yeah. That came from that idea came from localhost, right? It did. I thought it was really cool, right? And as opposed to just endless presentation,
we kind of well, we did a sort of Tyler did a fantastic overall
presentation.
Eric Hirschman did a fantastic overall presentation for everyone. And then we split everyone up and Eco sorry. Eco did Eco kicked it off with a fantastic presentation.
Kinda get the the rock stars up there. But then we divided
everyone up into, into groups and into smaller groups, and we kinda went off into
more or less smaller,
presentations,
but little bit more discussion format with, questions and things like that.
So that everyone could get a
dive into the individual projects
from the the leads on those.
And,
Justin did one for for fiber, for local host.
I did one for
Mugena and
sort of the the open source reverse engineering of electronics.
And
Schnitzel and Ryan and Jungly all did one for
LibreBoard,
Mugena, and HYDRApool respectively.
And it was really cool. I mean, we I think we each did three times. Right? We each did our presentation three times. And but it was by no means, the same thing over. It was kinda dependent on who was in the room and kinda what the vibe was and answering questions and
just going deeper
on
why
specifically
two fifty six is important in mining, which
as we're finding out, isn't isn't super well understood.
You know, we all talk to each other about this all the time, and so we're very convinced that this is important.
And so it was nice to, you know, have a receptive audience of people who may or may not known this and get to talk about it and present why why just why it's so important for this,
technology
that we sort of we all know and love and really think is essential in Bitcoin and and how this plays into the work that we're doing. And, of course, a plea for
a plea or a a cause made a a case made for for why it should be supported going forward. Yeah. It was That's a it's a good recap. Great recap. And at least for me
it reinforced
through some candid feedback we got during the event or at the dinner after the fact which is like, oh I finally understand what two fifty six does
or I finally understand how these four projects like interlink
and why I they love all have to happen in
seeing the light bulb turn on when people are like, oh, I get it. And it never
ceases to amaze me that like so many of those people have like been in our orbit for a long time. And
where I thought this stuff was well understood, it's like when I see those
light bulb, those moments,
I'm like, Man,
they're just now getting it. I'm so glad that they've arrived, and I appreciate it so much. But
I really thought I made this point clear
when I talked to them about it a year ago or two years ago. It
helps me try to figure out how to communicate this stuff better, I think is key because it never ceases to amaze me that despite all the communication around it, a lot of people just don't, they just don't get it. Well, it's complicated.
I think it's
not well documented.
A lot of people, if you're not into Bitcoin mining, you're like not into it at all, right? Right.
Then to Scott's point, we talk to each other about this
and so it may seem in our bubble that yeah, this makes perfect sense. Everyone must get it, right? Yeah, We're in an echo chamber.
For the
millionth time,
we do not sell bid access. Scott is not our slave manufacturing
bid access in that room behind him. Yes. Yes. It is a it is a weird concept. I don't even sell bid axes. It's weird. It's weird that I get a lot of, you know, people see my hat or something and they're like, oh, you work for bid axe? It's like, I do indeed work on bid axe quite a bit, but it's not a company and I don't sell them. Yeah. So to not put a bow in it, to tie it all together, and it was mentioned earlier in this pod,
the narrative we gave at this event that was successful in helping unlock people's understanding was eco talked pain, pain, pain. I wanted to do X, Y, and Z. I found out Bitcoin's permissioned,
banging my head against the wall. Bitcoin mining's permissioned, hard to do what I wanted. There's no open source building blocks. Okay, let's form a foundation around it. Let's get some funding. Let's bring in the domain expertise like Scott and the rest of the guys to architect and define these core projects that are those domain specific building blocks. What does not exist, what's not commoditized, what there's no open source references on in Bitcoin mining. And that's the hash board control board firmware and mining pool instance.
Together they make like a dev kit. If you want to make any type of Bitcoin mining system that happens to mine Bitcoin, but it can also plug into other things, right? Our dev kit happens to work as a suvi.
Shout out to Ryan.
Then these are the projects that you would scale up, modify, fork, change to your liking. And that's the point of our foundation. And then we're simultaneously starting to build up. We just talked about community infrastructure and forums and education, this podcast, newsletter, traveling to events, workshops, etc. The ecosystem that nurtures open source projects to gain this
snowball effect where you have community contributors
building on top of it. And that's how you get to that status quo like happened in computing with Linux. Yeah, we need the open source
solutions we're building to become integral parts of technology stacks built on top of this stuff so that the profitable
businesses
that sprout out of that can give back to the two fifty six Foundation if they want to
create this flywheel effect where it's like these tools are being used to support business models that we haven't even thought of yet, some that we know about but know that could be made a lot more efficient and better. And those businesses are making their operations so successful that they're able to fund the open source foundation that made their tooling possible in the first place. I liked your analogy, Tyler. Like, if you wanna start your aircraft company,
can
aluminum
is out there, right? The recipe is out there. You can just go get it. Maybe you need to specifically tailor it to your application, but aluminum is pretty well understood.
Imagine if you had to go figure out how to get aluminum out of its ore and produce it and mine it and all that stuff just to, like, build your your widget. It would take a lot longer. Yeah. Thanks. That analogy has
helped me and I received some good feedback on it. The recipe analogy, that's really what open source is. There's different licenses that you can attribute for CoffeeLeft, right? So that people are always getting credit or we're building and improving the recipe over time, right?
Instead of just forking it off into a million different directions or hiding your secret ingredient, right?
But the recipe analogy
does I think really dumb it down to help understand where there's no recipe for how to make a hash board and talk to ASIC mining chips. There's no recipe for a control board that has all the different IO you might want on it so that you can make your mining system do whatever you want. There's no recipe for an open source firmware that you can verify, inspect, modify,
add features to, build upon. And there's no recipe for an open source mining pool with direct from Coinbase payouts,
proper share accounting, aggregating,
and splitting rewards. So together you have the full recipe for a Bitcoin miner. And we are trying to say back to the beginning of the pod, that doesn't have to just be the shoebox. It might be. Maybe that's the most popular form factor. Who knows, right? But up until today the recipes haven't existed for anyone to go make the next dish that happens to mine Bitcoin. I think it's not going to be shoe boxes.
Yeah, we can do so much better. I know if the industrial miners like shoe boxes. No, don't think they do. Feel like the industrial miners definitely hate their customers. You don't think that publicly traded billion dollar companies like duct taping cardboard between different form factor
aluminum chassis rigs on shelves from
Uline
or whatever it is. Dude, like, they they have to hate their customers in order to subject them to the crap that they're selling. Yeah. Right. I mean, I think it's just like they make it absolutely as cheap as possible so they can lower the price of them and profit the most. And it's just like, here you go. Here's what you get. There's no competitors, so have fun with your Bitcoins. Yeah. Yeah. You're going to take whatever we give you. Good luck. Every generation like has a completely different form factor than the previous. I mean, don't need to go through all the pain points, but like what a shit show. Yeah. To say the least. Exciting time to be. Yeah. It was really helpful to have,
you mentioned it Scott, but Eric Hirschman from Gridless there giving
insight to
actual mining operations
in what would be described by a large publicly traded miner as like a non typical setup because they're off grid, they have much different power available,
they have much different climate conditions and air quality conditions and all these things that they really feel the pain of these machines that were almost designed for clean data center style rooms which they might not have I access love that photo he shows where the Watts Miner is like completely filled with bug guts.
Yeah.
But yeah by definition the machines they use should probably look different than the machines used in a pristine
hydro cooled data center connected to the grid run by a large publicly traded company. Right. Yeah, I mean just like, you know, if I want an economical vehicle to run to the grocery store and back, that's probably going to look a lot different than the vehicle I use to transport
a large quantity of freight across the entire country, right? That's
a good analogy. There's
different platforms for different use cases,
and
we're just not there yet with Bitcoin mining, but we've definitely seen
mean, hats off to all the pioneers
that have just figured out ways
to use these crappy shoebox miners that have been produced by Bitmain and WhatsMiner
to use those in ways that they're not meant to be used to sustain business models the way that they happen. I mean, it's like if you understand this stuff, it's just and appreciate it, it's just astounding
what people like Eric Hirschman have done at Gridless.
Just to think that we could have
a miner that's designed specifically for
their unique business application,
Just
think of how much they could turn up the juice on their operations if they just weren't fighting the technology,
if it was being
used, leveraged in their advantage. So now that we had this successful narrative according to the feedback from the fundraiser earlier in the month,
I think we got to keep polishing and fine tuning it so that this narrative clicks with the ASIC manufacturers,
the vendors, right? I don't think we've cracked that really.
Some folks individually
at various companies,
my personal experience is like the marketing people get it but they have no control over anything. They're just like, oh that makes sense.
Yeah.
So Yeah. And it's tough because usually, like, the people you're talking to are, the salesman, right, who are they're amicable. They wanna please everybody.
You know, that's in their nature as the
face of the company and a sales representative.
So when you talk to them, it's really easy to get the impression that you think they understand what you're saying, but that's kind of their whole shtick, that that's their job is to make you think that they understand you and appreciate you and are listening to you because that's how you, in turn, give them money.
But,
like, you know, talking to other people deeper down in the organization,
like the engineers,
it's
becoming apparent that some of them have been pulling their hair out because they recognize these issues and they know exactly what we're trying to do.
So I think we'll get there, but we're talking about completely
turning a narrative upside down that's been very, very deep rooted in this industry for a very, very long time.
So it's not going to be easy work. I think we're up to the task. We're not going away.
Sometimes
the funding is there and things are good and sometimes the funding is thin and
we're not making quite as much progress as we want to be, but we're chipping away at this stuff. And we're going to make it happen slowly but surely. It's tough because
these chip manufacturers,
they
obviously are spending a lot of money to design and develop and produce those chips. And I think a few of them would very much like to to sell to to get a couple,
you know, multimillion dollar orders for chips.
I think they would be happy to sell chips if, orders like that came through, but there isn't that,
that, like, groundwork there to support
to to support a company getting to the point in which they could place a multimillion dollar order for chips. Yeah. Right? So it's like this chicken and the egg because they're like, we wanna sell a million dollars worth of chips to one group, but there's no groups to sell a million dollars of chips to because they can't get them because no one wants to sell less than a million dollars. So We should
Two of these can bootstrap that. We should get Alex from HeapIt on the pod because I think he's the one example of a company that is probably at scale large enough to inquire with an ASIC vendor and say, Hey, we can probably order enough where you're going to even be willing to talk to us. Our mining systems look different. They do different things, right? Because the Canin Home miners, they are the ASIC vendor. They make them. But Heatbit, I think is the only instance of like large scale production of Bitcoin mining systems that use ASIC chips from other vendors, Right? And he's brute forced that. So that would be a really fun discussion to have because I agree. I think we all agree that there's this chicken and egg problem. The tools don't exist for those companies to do the prototyping,
the R and D to come up with the next system design. It can be done, but I think there's a lot of capital and extra effort required to do it the way Heatbit has done. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. It does seem like pulling teeth sometimes to just get a handful of ASIC samples
because you gotta prototype this thing and you gotta do a lot of that before you get to a place where you're gonna order $10,000
worth of chips, much less a million dollars worth of chips. So if we can we can get there, and I think you're exactly right. I mean, a Heatbit is a fantastic example of a company building mining products from scratch. Right? They're not they're not taking s 19 hash boards and reusing them.
They're
actually building these systems
from scratch, which is is what I think we're gonna see a lot more of in the future, I hope. Mhmm. But they're they're they are there now. Yeah. Cool. Cool to get Alex on the pot. What else is going on? Well Bitmain seems to have identified the heat reuse market or at least
Oh, yeah. I saw that. Right? What was going on there was like Bitcoin Asia in Hong Kong and then there was some world mining summit thing where Bitmain announced the next chip of the pro version of the S23 or something. And out of that event came
a handful of slides and quite a bit of time
dedicated
to heat reuse, the ant rack selling heat. So selling even them, right, as the ASIC chip manufacturer and also the system manufacturer, the system being the shoebox miner, they're now like broadening the scope of
what they're selling, what they're productizing,
what they're offering to include the heat as a core tenant there.
It'd be fun to see like all the different ASIC manufacturer
announcements,
like how much time is spent talking about heat reuse
over over the years? I think as as, you know, the Bitmens of the world
start getting out of their essentially,
you know, take it or leave it shoebox designs,
if they are, you know, forced to to open up a little bit. Right? Like
Yeah. If if you are a heating district in
Finland or whatever and, know, like, the government's involved and you're gonna buy this big massive minor heat reuse box. Right? Like, you're probably not gonna be as down with this sort of, like, here's our shitty API. Like, good luck. 100%.
You need it to interface with your, like, Modbus network or whatever you got going on there. And you probably also wanna have some assurances as to the, like, safety and security of the firmware, which we know from another project of ours is is not really up to snuff.
You know, it's like That's putting it lightly.
Yeah. You're so right, Scott. When I saw that announcement,
they will just have a slide of a Bitmain, whatever, hydro.
Sure, different markets have three phase power, I won't dog on that. We don't have it in North America in residential applications. But it's like a residential picture of a miner heating a house. And I'm like, Okay, wait a second.
Not to toot my own horn here, but I'm
pretty sure it's more complicated than that. I have a whole summit that I host every year about that. I'm pretty sure
it has to behave like a heating system, like a boiler, like a furnace, right? And that is inherently different than running a full time mining operation in your house. And no one can answer questions about that. They're just like, oh, you just dump the heat outside. That's the control. The control is the dry cooler outside. I'm like, Okay, We're talking about two different things. Yeah. You're not supposed to poke holes in their sales narratives, Tyler. Apparently, it's simple. Apparently, I was overthinking it. I shouldn't have wrote that stupid book. Yeah. Overachiever.
Yeah.
But yeah, that alludes to like the big gap there. We're talking about controlling mining systems in different integrated energy appliance settings where you really do need all the knobs available to you on a firmware level, right? Or all the connections,
be it digital or physical to connect to other infrastructure
to control that system, how it should behave. And we know, as Scott mentioned and EcoSmart that the Red Team program that we're now putting some resources towards and Schnitzel's been diving deep into.
Aren't these Things are
heating up, people. Stay tuned on the edge of your seat. We'll have more announcements soon. Yes.
There's definitely been
some big findings. I know we said we were gonna release the results of the the red team,
I don't know, a month ago or almost a month ago,
and we haven't yet done that. We've that is because there have been a lot of findings,
and
we need Ten days ago. Ten days ago. Ten days ago. Okay. Alright. Time's flying. Yeah. We wanna make sure we're doing this right,
and we
are actively working on it. So soon, TM. Yeah. If we just if we had just found, you know, some kind of BS,
like, it wouldn't be
you know, we we would have we would have shared
everything we found so far. So, you know, it's gotta be good because we're not saying shit about it. So
Well, of the vendors have asked us to coordinate with them and give them some extensions as well.
So we're following that good practice for responsible disclosure, but yeah, some interesting stuff. To say the least. It is definitely strange to be red teaming something that's not open and open source. Just reliant on them replying to your email? Yes. It's more like penetration testing, I guess, which traditionally companies will hire you to test their own product
and do penetration testing. Well, they're more than welcome to donate to us.
Yeah. One can hope. What kind of companies would do penetration testing? Would that be like a Red Hat thing? I imagine that a lot of the people that do that go
oh, I was thinking of Black Hat, the convention. But no, think it's like,
security firms,
right? There's there's several, like, security contractors out there that you can hire,
you know, and and companies will hire them and they usually have setups where, like, you know, we're not gonna tell you anything about our network break in and we promise we won't, like, you know, try and put you in jail for breaking into our network, that kind of thing.
I see.
And there's actually a
really cool podcast called The Darknet Diaries.
Yeah. I love that podcast. It's really good.
Shout out, Darknet Diaries. Jack Resider. Yes. Love that.
He talks a lot about about this and the various things that have been found and experiences they've had doing that.
And, you know, the these security researchers are amazing. They'll do all kinds of things.
They will do social engineering
and,
you know, like hacking,
computer hacking, and everything to try and get into these networks. And, of course, now with AI and deep fakes, you know, you can impersonate employees, and they just go And, all
yeah, I mean,
secure networking is hard. Yeah. Shout out If it were easy, everybody would do it. I remember Tesla like having competitions like hack into our cars. Yeah, totally. Well, overall
awesome fundraiser event. I think it was helpful for us as a team and as individual
grantees working on these projects to be together
all in the same room for a couple of days, refine our narrative that we talked about. I'm so glad everybody made it out there. That was the first time we've all been together since,
was it May
2025?
Yep. For TEMS, Texas Energy and Mining Summit in 2025,
Telehash two. Yeah,
great to see everybody. It was really fun. We've got such a rad team. I just, I don't know, the new ideas and the things we come up with just hanging out is fantastic.
And the coolest part is like,
mandate is to share all these things with as many people as we can. That's right. Yeah. Yeah. So definitely go check out the write up on
the website 256foundation.org
if you're curious to hear more about how that event went. I did record like a forty minute
more thorough version of my presentation from that exact event if you want to go see that breaking down how the foundation is structured and why we're doing what we're doing and how it fits into dismantling the proprietary mining empire, which means building the open source commoditized
building block based status quo of the future. Right.
And we're always looking for donations, hence the fundraiser. So if you're so inclined, 256foundation.org
for that too. Check it out. You did a great job at the fundraising event and I know having the space and time to get a little bit more in-depth with that presentation
is a good thing. Definitely check it out.
Understand That
the foundation. Yes, 100%. Tyler did a fantastic job. So did everyone coming together and putting together stuff for that event.
Tyler mentioned that we went to the Open Source AI Summit, which was in the days immediately preceding our event, also in the Presidio,
which was amazing. That was that was a very cool event. And it was it was really cool, I think, interesting to see the parallels
that Open Source AI
Yes. Is is sort of working through that we've been working through for maybe just a little bit longer with, open source mining. Right? There's this whole drama right now where the the frontier labs are basically
trying to get regulated by the government in a supposed attempt to squash their competition.
Right? And then there's this this thought that, you know, if they succeed in that, that that AI could become much more regulated and not available to as many people.
And that's actually definitely what will happen with regulation.
Yep.
And so they're they're kind of there's a lot of talk about the open source AI and these these open weight models
and,
you know, how that how that is,
you know, going to be essential
for people who rely on this technology to get done what they wanna do. Right? Sounds a lot like Bitcoin.
Yep. So I I thought that was neat. Wanted to be like Sam would be like, we're working on the same thing. This is really cool. And there was some Bitcoiners in attendance. We're we're, like, ringing the open source bell.
Over here. Over here. Over here. Now everyone's talking about the open source bell over there with AI,
which is good to have people interested in understanding
of open source technologies and the freedom it provides and permissionlessness.
But we can't forget about
core pillar of Bitcoin mining protocol, the Bitcoin protocol. Yeah. Yes. I mean, you know, there's a lot of people, ourselves included, who really, really rely on AI at this point. Right? And to have the government come in and be like, you know, you can't do that anymore because someone could do something bad with it would would just be
hugely detrimental to to progress
Yeah. And, you know, freedom. I mean, there's
there's cases where people are using this technology to really fundamentally
improve
their freedom
and
to have that be denied because someone could do something bad with it just would would be terrible. Right? Yeah.
I think it was funny timing. The day of our event, which was Saturday the twelfth so the day after the open source fundraiser or open source
AI event concluded
was when Dario
and Sam Altman and Elon all chimed in and were all like yeah maybe we should be regulated
And then Trump was just like, shut up nerds. Keep building. It's so ridiculous, dude. That is the right response, man. They they've just been doing all this sketchy stuff to show
how bad their technology is, which is really weird.
But it makes sense when you figure they want to get this regulation that only they could comply with. Yeah, they want regulatory moats.
That's the objective here. That's
the objective. Yeah, that whole What was it like?
OpenAI,
like, accidentally their AI went rogue and hacked Hugging Face? Yep. Yeah. Give me a fucking break, dude. I mean, it's come out now that they basically
didn't put any any stops on their AI. And so, like, of course, it it didn't break out. It just, you know, did what it did.
Yeah.
And
then they're like, woah. This is the danger of AI. It's like, you know, yeah. Your your gun can definitely kill someone if you point it at them and pull the trigger. Like, it's just Yeah. It's a false flag event is what that was. Yeah. Yeah. So keep your head on a swivel, people,
and stay
vigilant. Ask your AI how Bitcoin mining works. See what you learn. Highly recommended. Do that. It's
the, it's really good at explaining that stuff now, which is awesome. Or point it to the IP address of your miner, little Bitaxe or whatever home miner you have. Right? Just poke around. Yes. Just poke around. You can learn a ton really quick. Like it's never been easier to learn how this stuff works. Then
keep the party going and learn how to make it better. I've learned a lot over the last couple of days dumping that what was the file I dumped from the BidX? The NVB?
Oh, yeah. That's the non volatile storage.
NVS.
Yeah. NVS.
Yeah. So that was like
you're just very, like, nonchalantly in the chat. We're like, oh, yeah. Just
put put in this command and dump the the nvs
dot bin file,
and, you know, let me know what's in there. And I'm like, okay. Cool. So, like, I go and sit down to do it, and it, like, dude, it took me hours to get there,
and I I never should have told me. I I was, like No. No. No. I I had to mansplain this to Eko. Like, here's the command. If you have any problems, you could ask me.
No. I had to I had to figure it out on my own. I wasn't gonna let you down. So I, like, I was determined,
and I think it I think it took me, like, two, maybe three hours.
I may have made that sound a little more dramatic than it actually was. But,
like, I had never even connected a Bidax over USB before.
So, like, I was like, okay. What the fuck am I doing? How does this I so I've got, like, some very basic information
from that I can glean from Scott's, like, one sentence in the chat, and then I used AI to help me, like, fill in the blanks.
And,
yeah, like, I installed the the Bidax tool
and was able to connect and communicate with the Bidax over USB
and get it to dump that file.
And, like, everything was awesome. And then I, like, sent the file to you. And then immediately afterwards, I'm like, I wonder what was in that file. I should, like
so I, like so that was, like, a whole another thing to, like, make it readable in, like, human
readable format. But I figured that out and then, like, saw what was in there. I'm like, oh, that's my SSID
for my home Wi Fi network, and there's my fucking password in plain text. That's weird. And then, like, I'm like, oh, there's, like, all the SSD and passwords I've ever connected this Bidax to. I'm like, holy shit, man. I'm like, okay. So then, like, I think probably the the the third hour of that endeavor was just updating my Wi Fi SSID
and password and then reconnecting all the devices in my house. That is a good good exercise.
It
was a it was a fun
field trip I I went on. Yeah. I was thinking about that a lot,
yesterday.
Like,
you know, this is very common for,
an IoT device to just store your Wi Fi password in its nonvolatile memory in the clear. Right? That's that's how they're all done.
But it is kinda fucked up because, yeah, there's your your WiFi password right there in it. Yeah. So if someone just physically gets access to an IoT device, whatever, takes it from your house, they are just walking out with a copy of your Wi Fi password? Yeah, yeah. Internal
storage.
And I think my biggest concern
isn't so much,
okay, so I send the file to you, So Scott's got my SSID and my WiFi password, but he's nowhere
near WiFi range.
So what is he really gonna do with it from his geographic location? That's not that big of a concern,
but out of an abundance of caution, it's a good idea just to update that information. But I think the more interesting thing someone could do with information like that
is
in a targeted attack scenario.
Let's say, Tyler, they knew
they were able to see what your SSID was and
the password,
and they knew like you were going to be at like a coffee shop or at a Bitcoin event or a conference or, you know, whatever.
And, like, they could potentially
create
a decoy
WiFi network that looks like one of the ones you have saved in your phone, and your phone would automatically connect to it or could potentially automatically connect to it. And then, you know, it looks like a a router that you are familiar with and trust, but it's really not. And then, you know, that could open up other attack vectors. Okay.
Yeah. That's scary. It is like, it's ridiculous to think that people would normally do this, but I definitely have, like, a separate network that I put even my bid access on. And especially the, you know, random IoT devices that people send me, things like that. Right? It's like a separate network. It can't connect to my main network.
You know, it's not totally foolproof because it has Internet access, but, you know, it can't try and connect to my Yeah. Machines.
Network security seems to be a recurring theme in the era of
AI
as something that can be brute force penetrated more often than you think. Yeah. I wanna look at storing it like a hashed version
in the in a BitX firmware.
There's gotta be a way to do that.
Yeah.
It's not just sitting there in the clear, but, you know, it the BitX does need to send the Wi Fi password to the
to the SSID
to get it to to connect to it, to connect to the access point. Right? So it does need to have the ability to decrypt it. So that's when it's really difficult is to have you could have a hashed or, you know, encrypted version of the password on the device, but the device does need to know how to be able to decrypt it. So that that ends up being that ends up being difficult to do. Right? Yes.
And I hate to do this, but, guys, I gotta go run an errand, so I'm gonna end the show here,
And we'll see you all next week. Until next time. All right. Sorry. See you guys. Sorry for the abrupt ending, but until next time. Later. Later.